[Musique]
ou encore touché une partie est la muse
et parce qu'il soit disant qu'il va
aller travailler faire les transférer
cours des travaux pour les allemands
j'ai vu ma maman qui était triste je
sais papa il a fait à peu près 20 mètres
puis s'est retourné il m'a dit philippe
soit sage avec la moment là son dernier
mot qui m'a dit élu après la tournée le
dos ou les parties avec les autres
camarades puis après je les plus les
jamais revu
philippe avait six ans son père ses
frères ses cousins huit membres de sa
famille ont été fusillés ce jour là avec
trente et une autres victimes un
massacre en représailles d'une attaque
du maquis contre les allemands et lors
de laquelle un général avaient été tuées
quinze jours plus tôt à et aux bons 300
habitants ce 27 septembre reste à jamais
une journée particulière depuis 2005 un
piquet d'honneur de gendarmerie
participent à la commémoration
une initiative du maître de cérémonie il
est important que l'armée française soit
sa présentation au mémorial comme celui
des tombes ont de surcroît découvre le
village décoré de la légion d'honneur
tout ça pour une question de devoir de
mémoire déjà dans un premier temps et
puis surtout pour le lien armée nation
je crois qu'il est important que les
forces armées soient présentes sur des
mémorial aussi porter au point de vue
histoire notre président macron j'ai vu
pas gelé vu aller à oradour sur glane
vous l'aurez bien qu'une fois ils sont
informés et qu'ils viennent nous en
aurait une fois compatir un petit peu
de ce qu'on a souffert